this video is sponsored by better help as three
people who are proud to be in therapy we are
proud to be sponsored by these guys citizens of
the reject Nation it is time for Loki season 2
episode 5 today after last week's Cliffhanger
cannot wait to see how they completely resolve
everything in one episode no no I'm excited to
see what's going on John how are you I am lowy
forward to this G okay not bad not bad I am
highkey excited to be enthralled I am yes yes
um I've been on a jet ski before leave a like
leave a like subscribe click the notification
get notified when a reaction for the last episode
of the season is up here on this channel thank you
to everyone who's been buying some RR merch
that means the world we're all wearing some
RR merch he got a lowy one hell yeah I'm talking
about last but not least massive thank to all who
have been supporting us at our patreon becoming
super sexy regz that's where you get the full
length Reaction watch along for Loki where you SN
up with your own copy over there we cover several
shows exclusively with highlights and watch Longs
included all righty gang let's see what's going
on jet skis seos one of these calling your name
Mobius I don't know about calling is this the
episode of jet skis are we going to Mobius his
timeline what's the over under on Victor timely
getting spaghetti meaning Kang now has his power
because he's become part of time itself I think
that's how he conquers time I think that was the
path I'm not sure Victor timely is permanently
gone honestly saying I think that Kang put
timely on the path to becoming mom spaghetti
to be Time Lord of mom spaghetti the Palm sweat
is time love this 2001 of Space Odyssey Marvel
bumper for boing sounds of
mourning where are you waking
up is he in some void the
construct still in the
TVA alone where's all the pie did he
time slip is he Beyond time he's the only
God low key who remains Sylvie was a God
but I don't know if they can be on the
same cool jump
cut damn the matching on the editing
is phenomenal here and they're all
like moving shots 29 fail sa mode initi
fail safe mode time there it is okay
so it is what's happening oh go to the
location the shot that I oh damn where is
everybody oh hey me what does he learn hello H
that must be a later moment
we're going to see him hear
him it doesn't look that far in the future or
past though now he's going to pick up the book
He's only slipping by a little bit I think I
think the bigger the Distortion the shorter the
slip hello good call Koy nicely
done big Distortion short time
that's why it was only like a hallway jump
oh oh no I thought time might be converging
but it looks like it's fully splitting temporal
fungus oh we're going to get this shot I'm
been waiting for I feel it oh match with it
is it fail fail mode what did he plan oh
miss minutes is in control I love these
visual oh that was a genius open that was
Fant fantastic please wake up in front of
the store I've been waiting for the shot now
wake up at jet ski shot J shot oh the letters
they're going away they're we're going to have
a singi I think it's going to be a singularity
I think we're going to have one are we
getting Prime timeline in show causing
them to need to find prime timeline people in
Deadpool 3 let's just see what happens 2025
casy casy KY King the
[Music] conquer what time prison have
they locked you in the greatest Ste very
much [Music] so SpongeBob's waking
up oh this is probably Casey's real
life oh you're right this is
going to be Casey's life damn
we're out of the TVA now we're going to find
out we're going to see Owen Wilson with a jet
ski next we're going to see people's lives
19 1962 are we on Alcatraz it's said Branch
timeline Casey I got you here his name's
not Casey who are you not again how'd you
get here how did I get where elcat what
yes I don't know what's happening Casey
Frank why is this guy calling you Casey
been calling you Frank the whole time you
got to find your own way off this rock sorry
pal man Frank's a dick [Music] yeah that's
one way I like this night photography you can I
actually see there it is J now I have to call a
thing what point is time is this it's the time
theater from the first season which we didn't
see in this season is it when he's about
to watch himself and like okay so we got
a good cast on here for you he she was a
pediatrician you might forget how bad it
hurt over the next 6 weeks so I'm going to
write a little reminder on [Music] here life
is pain I wonder if the climbing tree thing
will come back tree branches timelines where
are we I Wonder Why the he's Tethered to them
because they were all there at the same time
yeah it's happening get that wind I can die
he's sitting in front of a green screen or
something in a phot he's in a photo shoot
open in front of you yes so talk to me
Cleveland Ohio who's more interested in
a dirt bike well they say the personal
watercraft is kind of the thinking man's
dirt bike jump up on this bad boy I'm good
sorry call me if you change your mind
this is so cathartic great Donuts today
[Music] Dale wacky waving inflatable arm flailing
Tube Man how could he not get up here Dale crazy
I don't get it you're here every day of the week
except Sunday 9 to 5 career man the TVA is gone I
think you mean ATV [Music] and you don't remember
me either no I do you were in just the other day
right your son's on line three sorry single
dad a sing single dad he has a son your other
son f as once tell I'll call him back too Papa
Mobi two sons that's why I didn't want to know
wow he seems like he has the exact EXA same
personality OB Pasadena Great Library this is
our tank contingent Steven King in the background
he's one of the great I read everything he does
have to check it out is he a king variant so
he's not a creation then I can give you cash
I don't need a receipt or anything yeah but I
have to ring it up or oh no I told you to stop
putting your sci-fi books on our shelves shut
up a what expecting in not provoking genre well
nobody buys it here oh so he's like the elron
hopper yes oh oon Boris I love the utilization
of all these different locations though all right
science OB this episode is titled science fiction
science SL fiction ohic is he the inventure of
the TVA his is the most similar great re response
CH s what I'm about to tell you is going to be
hard to believe he'll believe it though he'll
finish the sentence for me of course I believe
you it's a dream come true one of my characters
has come to life and needs my help reminds me of
what happens in the sons of uran my most popular
book of all time I'm sure I can find your copy
somewhere around here or Stranger Than Fiction
I had to get a PhD to keep my day job teaching
theoretical physics at CCH you have no idea how
hard it is to breing hey look at this here's a
Cy you're are one lucky man you are one lucky
man I love all the yellow colors here it's like
what they last off Loft you traveling to a place
that doesn't exist anymore is equally impossible
and therefore it's something you might be able to
do equally possible as well doesn't sound like
science no but it does sound like fiction you
need to learn how to control your time slipping
oh and they you can have ultimate power Deja Vu
you keep ending up around exactly the people
you're looking for because you're not just
slipping in time you're also moving around space
not just physically a better version of one of
those Tamp hats you make it sound like it's a
good thing could be with science it's all what
and how with Fiction it's why yeah just do it
all right can you go back to that moment where
the Cliffhanger was of episode three focus in on
that why you need to save the TVA if his why is
strong enough you need to save the TVA because
literally huning in on a character's motivation
their goal and why very metac commentary way
I mean like he becomes the god of stories it's
interesting if this fiction narrative becomes
how he becomes the god of Stories versus
Mischief I've been in this acting class you
must be doing something wrong because it
really feels like the time sliping is the
answer you're trying too hard let go this
equation proposes a tase me bro now we know
that electrical pulses don't initiate time
slipping okay let's forget about the time slipping
time spping is clearly the key maybe the place in
time you're looking for still exist but you just
don't know what to look for it hold this yeah oh
let's explain some complex theoretical physics
with props we get the band back together every
one of your friends has a temple aa oh it's time
to recruit it'll be like coordinates and we can
use these coordinates to get back to that moment
in time no we don't have one of those temp PS you
talked about well can you build one I would
have to invent it all from scratch it could
take a whole lifetime oh we're watching a Time
Loop here this is how we got created wa he's the
one who created the temp pass he picked up the
journal though he's going to show him his own
Journey he's doing what Kang did yeah yeah who
exactly so Loki's inventing the tva's beginning
yes yeah you wrote it so I am going to write
a bestseller this is all he who remains plan
I'm telling you that's why he slipped to that
moment to pick up the book and then slipped
again to gather the people let's um so Kang is
making this happen hey just just let me that's a
problem just let me believe they're going to
fix this guys no K yes aadel Mobius any toy
found outside your room going to be classified as
garbage is he burnt yeah he's burnt what is that
Brad Kevin who gave you the matches it's Kevin
feige time travel Kevin get Sean go get him come
on did you follow me home no no is that your my
way to uh the uh I I'm sorry I couldn't stick
around back there I was um I was in a bit of a
time crunch you were good choice of worth are
you still in the market cuz I have something
I got something I want to show you come here
what do we got he's a man of two jet skis a
beautiful Union of Form and Function that's
lovely they really are and it breaks my heart
but you want a drink can I get you a beer no
no no I I'm fine thank you no Mobius Mobius
that's your name I think you have me mixed up
with someone else now you see the thing is I
don't Mobius is your real name is it his real
name Mobius was his given name okay hold that
thought I'm going to go check on my okay it's
okay I don't want any is stranger nature going
on I'm a friend I know you are I'm a friend too
jeez who how did you build a temp pad so fast
I don't know if I say 18 months is fast well
I had to take a break and move out when I lost
my job and my wife left me you ruined his life
now that's so funny
oh oo oh yeah I love the janky doorways
you saved my life when I first arrived
you saw something in me that I hadn't
seen in myself now it's time for you
to do the rescuing Loki are you really
my friend I am who's he is he my friend
the the TVA you once told me it was the only
life you'd ever known my jet SK man he's got
two sons what my boys they'll be fine look you
can come back the moment you left oh you were uh
you were at the shop earlier right whoa your
boys W even know you're gone yeah but I will
oh all of existence is in grave danger I don't
care your boys are in danger too you're asking a
father to give up all this what were you calling
[Music] meus it's a pretty cool name yes it is
it's interesting how other than Obie everyone
else kind of feels a little bit antithetical to
the profession that we giving at the TVA is going
to sound strange she like harms people instead of
helps them he does not know fun and he's a man who
gives fun Casey is sweet and innocent where his
her is a criminal yeah I mean technically he's a
fiction writer who now makes science sure science
[Music] fiction the TV Avengers you've assembled
a team very special team I'm really enjoying the
creativity behind all of this there is one part
of me it's probably going to wait till after
the next episode is done and I'm wondering if we
should have spent a little bit more time in the
isolation with Loki and trying to solve this we're
kind of just getting everyone reassembled again
really quick Fair after such a cliffhanger eight
25 minutes later stealing it's a what are we some
sort of temporal Squad Don Opus is my space name
space name is this everyone no Sylvie and we are
going to need dinner I wonder if Sylvie actually
knows and remembers and is just accepting all
this she didn't want it I could go for some hash
browns o want to make flurry pretty bad bless you
thank you McDonald's was really mad about that
canot show our food deteriorating it lasts for
decades save money on that show I know you don't
know who I am of course I know who you are yeah
what she has all of time as a God she's seen more
she would have seen this their lives area after
the Los yeah I know I was there this isn't how
I thought the scene was going to play out what
exactly were you ex talk to a Raider control
it get in the car I'm buying you a drink how
long has she been here M's life at the TVA was
taken from him so is b15s OB Casey was prisoner
zaniac nice would have chosen to stay the TVA was
the only life he' ever known gave him purpose it
was never his choice to begin with Loki showing
them something that they cannot unsee didn't get
a choice I can't without you I want a life
I want to live you work at McDonald's that
ising but she can't travel no health insurance
maybe she Works enough I want the TVA back and
what do you want I want my friends back oh he
doesn't want to be alone I thought it was going
to be you want to be a hero he wants to be good
I think he wants her to I don't want to be alone
we're both [Music] selfish again consistently
exploring that gray your friends are back where
they belong for all time always but without
them where do I belong we're all writing our
own stories now start boy science fact maybe
that's why he was sort of just giving into the
whole TBA identity because he just needed a place
to belong this whole time an anchor still a lost
boy you should all go home she's reading this
book Guitar monkey rough day po better
rough life this we either cure what's
sailing you or make it a whole lot worse
like good music can good needle drop
shot what a toe blog off shot to her head
she has to like it's just like a drug train
spotting shot used musically that was beautiful
she just like dropped in and dropped out to
music I wonder if they knew they
were going to use this song whoa
what just happened in the background
there did someone just time slip in
and out oh what's happening
we are Frozen no we are not
frozen oh cups keep
[Music] disappearing holy
[__] Sylvie take your headphones off
experience time dilations making it a whole lot
worse whoa that's cool
whoa no record store guy it seems like
she's immune to this love how this is
happening to like a song that feels
like a drug trip oh it's definitely a
drug trip oh yeah TV acid look at that
shot man it looks like parasitic the
way it works yeah it looks like like some
kind of weird fungus or like tapeworms or
something activate that pad
yep what about the TVA TVA you're fine without
it he lost his wife and everything yeah no they
aren't everything's falling apart oh we can go
back we can stop B Loom from melting down they
are going to go back just immediately fix it
I still think K got canged up from that moment
though we need to read the collective temporal
Aura of everyone in this room on the temp P hey
I didn't take it you can rob every Bank you
like when this is done we need that temp pad
now great but I still didn't take it Frisk oh no
no it's like another version of getting dusted
absolutely yeah it was a fic
problem time slip intentionally
come on man you got to master
the time slipping I have to go back to see my
boys single father no is this [Music] it
where do you go when you get spaghetti
there's nowhere left to go oh not immune I
like how it feels like ghostly in a way too
so haunting and uncom like there's a bit of a
personality to it it's ethereal yeah practicing
my voice Focus intentional your time slip go
away if I can go anywhere follow the threads
do you think that what makes a loky a lowy is the
fact that we're destined to lose he did it [__]
yeah go back a little bit further yeah
we can go back go back a little bit
further everything's falling apart I was
such a cool edit but there must must be
something we can do I did it what now is
he the one that takes the temp pad I did
it did [Music] what I took the almanac I made
all the sports bets it's not about where when
or why how what was it about it's about who
that was the last question absolutely all
of us Doctor Who I can rewrite the
story God of stories is born God of
story wow we're going right back to it right
back to it so they going to like try again and
fail multiple times yeah fail could be like
a doctor strange dorm yeah he's come here to
bargain with Kang yeah he's just going to keep
trying until they figure it out I honestly think
he's he still under the plan of Kang if you think
about it he who remains wanted him to rule the TVA
and now he's got this power of time more than
anything else you know damn he's been granted
a brand new power Loki he's going to oversee all
of the timelines yeah as the keeper or is the god
of stories ultimately he who remains wins and then
it doesn't factor into any of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe yes no other's power is never used again
variety writes another article about nothing sure
to forward to reading that culmination of three
years of nothing you got to contrive your news
from somewhere when no one's allowed to work if
that was a strike during the end game it'd be
like three days before rapping then they wrote
the ending for Tony Stark last minute rewrites
and I think Miss minutes is still serving he who
remains his big plan and yeah I think she's still
in control boy wow a lot to dissect here I can
only imagine that with the amount of existential
dread and those feelings of loneliness that when
you're thinking about wow you need people in your
life you need some help you need some people to
talk to yeah and not just any kind of help yeah
you need best you know what guys before we do the
review I I think I need to give a message to the
audience of course all right can can you guys
just leave for a second I'm going to just just
get out the frame let me just do this today's
episode is sponsored by better help I know with
that we often joke around here quite a bit on the
channel but I wanted to speak a little bit more
sincere during this specific sponsor and I'll
start off by saying this that you know with any
sponsor they usually give like suggested things to
consider uh when talking about the sponsor and one
of their suggested things was was a question that
they had there that went along the lines of like
have you ever laid awake with your thoughts
racing wishing for a moment of silence and I
thought to myself well yeah that's my secret cap
I got know that feeling way too well and it's in
those quiet moments where you're battling your
own mind where you are seeking Clarity the most
and you may have heard me talk about this on
the channel before the better part of a decade
now therapy has undoubtedly been one of my main
anchors before there was ever the real rejects I
was diagnosed with PTSD type 2 bipolar and ADHD
so uh needless to say I needed some therapy and
through its guidance I've Unearthed deeper layers
of myself cultivate a richer relationships and
just have a more profound understanding of my
emotions and one of the best parts about it is
it's giving me a space where it's free from
judgment where I found my voice and learned
the art of truly listening not just to others but
also to myself I've talked a little bit about how
this year I've focused a lot more on my physical
health and hitting the gym a little bit more often
and in all sincerity I do view therapy as like the
a gym for your mental health a place where you can
really nurture your mental well-being and it is
an experience that has been quite transformative
so much to the point that you know I would say say
at least half of the people that you see that come
here on the channel are in therapy as a matter of
fact I know one of them their therapist is With
Better Health I often joke that like I've been
in therapy since it was underground why I joke
like that is because I I see now in the past few
years a lot more people have been going to therapy
which is fantastic I'd love seeing that so I will
say that if in your heart if you have been seeking
therapy or contemplating going to therapy I highly
encourage you I urge you to consider better help
before I ever saw some ad for better help I
had heard other people people who had been with
better help and had really given strong in-person
testimonies to me their online platform is crafted
with care keeping your comfort in mind starting it
as simple as answering a few questions and really
important to remember it's a journey and I really
love this because I've had at least like three
therapist in my life so if you ever feel the need
to change your therapist better help understands
and allows it without any fuss trust me that's a
massive benefit so for a journey of self-discovery
and mental well-being turn to betterhelp embark
on this heartfelt Joy at betterhelp.com that's
I talked for quite a bit there so many thoughts
on the episode out of that please John go Joe go
John Go I mean no go go Johnny [Music] Ranger you
know I'm just glad take it away John I personally
was quite enthralled by this episode course you
were you love everything I love everything I don't
have any criticisms for read the Variety article
clearly part of mar part story like this is all
Kevin's design whatever is the god of stories in
her world yes no no the Variety article lady oh
that yes of course was like I'm gonna read a lot
of news and just put up one article pretend it's
new newo hey you know there's nearby there's an
editor going we need something the strike is on
and Marvel is popular but not as popular so thus
the perfect time yeah we can't talk anymore about
how DC is in champ there's nothing new to report
any who I really enjoyed this episode uh I think
yes I need to dumb it down now John you trying
to play to the haters what's going on pick a
side John I thought this was a rich existential
experience oh now he's an elite using big words
like existential uh it's good uh and sop how do I
be sophisticated where are the Easter eggs I need
the Tik Tock cut COI it's almost Christmas all
right a different holiday all together Shane black
Loki episode six yes anyway okay for real that's
my review starting now I think that certainly I
may be the most enthralled of us in some ways
uh but you know like I I don't know how people
are going to feel about like the pound-for-pound
like Revelations plot-wise as we got this episode
but uh I I've really really really been loving
and appreciating the feeling that this show in
particular has been giving me that is kind
of a rare feeling it's the kind of feeling
I associate with like a par any particularly
rich and interesting sci-fi and it comes with
like stray episodes particularly great Twilight
zones or things like that or like an amazing
Doctor Who uh something like this is really
embodying this sense of yeah something is off
and you can't quite tell what the source of that
is and it permeates the mood of everything and I
really enjoyed the sort of somber lonely mission
that Loki was on this episode seeing all of our
different friends in their you know potentially
sacred timeline lives I just I loved the mood the
aura the atmosphere and the puzzle of figuring out
the time slipping figuring out should we or should
we not try and save the TVA why are we doing that
I just thought this was rich with a lot of stuff
I am often hoping that like things like this so
and then I'll let you guys talk things like this
are are they make me kind of furious because I'm
like clearly you guys are capable of coming up
with something that is both satisfying as like a
big superhero you know Blockbuster thingy but also
that has a really authentically science fiction
feel and level of thought and meta thought put
into it yeah um so that's I thought that was was
quite well exemplified in this episode and even
though it might not be the most revelatory in
terms of like nuts and bolts and plots um this
might be towards the top if I was to rank the
episodes for me might not be the top but it's
it's pretty close like I really loved a lot of
this I uh almost kissed you there did little mic
to M little mic to mic little syv Loki action uh
I really like that the show feels like it trusts
us to take its time I definitely had to adjust
my expectations about 10 minutes in when I was
like oh okay we're going to do like a like a new
um moment for our lead versus the story directly
carrying the plot like we had to like charge up
the the narrative in the isolated individuals
in order for the big finale and I actually once
I realized that really enjoyed the episode but
there was definitely a moment where I was like oh
we're rushing to this and then I was like oh no
we're slowing down for this and I had to like
reind of calibrate cuz I I was was afraid it
was going to do what it did and then try to go
back once I realized what it was doing and I'm
really glad it just did what it did and then like
kind of let you breathe in the emotional beats of
that because it could have been like and now
we're back to the TVA and I was like oh okay
no we're going to do this and give it some time
to breathe but I agree with John that did cause
it to not have as many revelatory moments but
it did give this beautiful ponderous we all had
these moments of mentioning like The Melancholy
and the existential dread and the man that that
drop in Dropout song of like your loose uh like
LSD lucid dreaming uh wonderful oh like there was
a weight to this episode early Doug I also like
that this season finally gave Sylvie some time
uh because I do feel like we've missed out on a
lot of Sylvie um but I think the thing I like the
most is it was stuff that I thought was going to
happen from the jump that delivered in a more fun
way so like I I multiple times in the episode was
like this is going to happen this going to happen
but then when it actually happened I was like
oh nice and like I called the god of stories in
the pilot but also like I put out the comic rexs
today like I always do Midway through the season
and six seconds in is when he's first called
the god of stories because at the end of the
last episode I was like somehow they're going to
make that a thing I thought it was going to be the
finale it ended up being here but they're doing
a beautiful thing kind of like Civil War where
they hit certain beats in the comics in new ways
and this is hitting certain beats where I still
think Victor timy's demise is either the birth of
Kang or his manifesting into Kang I that moment is
not a negative for Kang and I'm really excited
to see that pay off because I feel like I have
all the ingredients in the pie but I'm really
excited to see him bake it it's it's Dr Doom
now oh Dr Doom that's right right so Dr Doom has
been confirmed yeah the and Robert T J showing
upet Wars and also yeah don't worry about it's
going to be fun also blade is $100 million yeah
and there's four women the four I feel like
blade would be 100 Milli and M goth is the
lead it's very confusing Lake Bell's there too we
don't know why I mean we know blad did disaster
that's why it's out this year right say none of
it's new 2023 but uh yeah think about the variety
articles and none of it's the it's literally just
repeating articles thing the thing we're saying is
like it's not that we disagree with it it's that
none of this is really new it's also literally
framed to be so negative when it's like yeah we
know things have been bad why are you telling us
in one condense it's like now that's what I call
[__] like we know it's [__] that's happening
but they finally confirmed that water is wet ah
yes and Marvel um anyway anyway uh I'm sure we'll
talk more about it on Saturday we have a live
stream we're doing um so yeah I I I really I
would rank this one like my third favorite out
of the five four or five yeah 41532 yeah 41 uh
yeah that's exactly where I put it why we almost
kissed yeah I I would rank this uh number three
out of them and I I really did enjoy it a lot
and I agree with the entire there's no point of
me of repeating everything you guys said repeat
everything yeah existential dread Mel it was all
great poetic it lovely I I love that they gave us
a few things that we have been um sort of aiming
for and hoping for obviously Mobius on a jet ski
is something that we have all been clamping at
the bit like we want to see that happen and
I like the portrayals a lot of what we got
there's some I wish we kind of got to live in a
little bit more I'll just say this I agree with
all the positives I think the right thing to do
when you're doing and say all the positives and
say they negatives or the criticisms for later my
criticism about it is more so wondering how I'll
ultimately feel about it in the end once episode
6 is done because you know one thing that has come
out about Marvel lately but now that they've
officially finally hired some showrunners is
that they've essentially been making movies and
then dividing it up into like several hours and
whereas here Loki I would say that they they
really do feel like they have thought episode
per episode and where each episode should really
end and I don't feel like that none any of them
have been filler they've all felt substantial
and necessary what was missing for me like I
love the turns that we've got in here I love the
answers I like how this was a a big Journey on
Loki really establishing like in season one he was
understanding his own true identity and here he
was understanding connection and that these people
are really a big part of his camaraderie and that
the key to the time slipping and understanding
that a lot of this is a power from within it's
not just something that is happening to him I
think is great I really love learning that and
watching all all of that UNF I think Tom Hilson
gives another great performance what was missing
for me that I actually do feel is a bit rushed
is you get such a great Cliffhanger of what has
happened to the TVA what has become of everyone
lok's the only one who really remembers and it's
this journey that I don't really feel a sense of
catharsis on because it's the the journey is about
like getting the team back together and getting
them to remember reassembling and uh you know they
talk a lot about goals and wise here and putting
them on the path for why to do this and I I kind
of feel like we got to assembling them all pretty
much like really quick and not letting us live in
the I guess the the hopelessness of the situation
enough if this wasn't a Marvel show I would have
liked an eight episode series and i' had I'd had
one of of filler not filler in the negative sense
but filling in the time between Brad and the
interrogation like like or make that episode
like two-parter and then I would have loved this
to be a two-parter between his isolation and then
a longer rallying of the troops yeah like really
if I'd make it eight those are the two beats you
would you would uh you could let the debate
linger a little bit longer of why they should
come together of why of the sacrifices that are
potentially at hand like Loki's not Loki Mobius
is family uh like we didn't really get to see B1
15's life and the moment where he accepts that
he needs others got moved quickly it I I wanted
that to like stick and I get that that's the The
Epiphany but I I like when that has a resolution
because that's the moment we have I guess what
was missing for me was a little bit of the drama
a little bit of the struggle and to me it kind of
got it's it it was to the point where I was like
well we know that we're going to be resolving this
and I feel like there was too much of an awareness
on the writer's end to be like we know they're
going to resolve this so let's just get to it
and I I feel like we need in order to feel the
catharsis of them finally coming back together of
them finally doing this you need to have a moment
where you were not feeling the finally it was
just more like we know we're getting there and
we started getting there within like 10 minutes
I hope they don't fix it next episode man I feel
like so so that's my I know know I know I I know
out of the three of us I spent like the most time
you know gestating on a uh on a criticism that I
had and a desire but but I would still rank this
number three because everything that I liked about
it is the thing same things I would Echo that you
guys said Echo trailer apparently coming out Yay
good job Marvel over Market everything all at once
and so all the episodes are already live thei
finale finale before marveles comes out put it
on Tik Tok in 15 seconds we need to compete with
the fact that Invincible is also premiering at the
same time two things at good thing they're not
both on Amazon we want to have a I think that's
di so yeah that is my that is my one concern but
again I love the tone I love the symmetry of these
shots I loved Obie's performance I like where the
theories let you speculate towards this it feels
like they're actually giving you a reward with
that a lot of times with a lot of these Marvel
shows I think what ends up happening and maybe
Co still doing it too much to a certain extent
you know where you like over theorize was in
this episode he was all over this episode right
but I would say that they they do within this
season alone they eventually like lean into
things where like oh damn some crazy theories
are coming true you know like I the thing I'm
really latching on to is that we are watching
he who remains ultimate plan unveil in fact when
you look at the previously on the first thing
they open up with something from he who remains
talking about like this is the plan and eroded
I was like I'm pretty confident that whatever
everything is a uh mislead of of heroic conquering
or heroics climbing up the ladder that everything
that we think is heroism is really a step of the
direction yes I think that is exactly what we're
watching unfold is something truly malevolent
what if they build the timeon for him like what
if that's what his power like what if putting it
back together is what allows him to con need to
build my bigger it can't end well I don't think
it could I I don't think it will end well um and
and that's what I I've been that's what I've
been really loving about the show um and the
performance is all around so in this episode in
the background there was a 25 and the 25 in the
time theater this episode five five times time
is 25 but in issue 75 a wolverine gets Adam man
takeen out X-Men 75 25 time 3 Deadpool three he's
in the next episode Wolverine confirmed yeah Dead
3 25 is 75 Adam anti pull down that's how you
used to convince me but then now I just go I'd
like to rather be here and be like oh [__] Koy
was right no you're my story for right my story
also the second Ora Boris I love that he's an
Ora Boris for Kang as well as an or Boris for
Loki like the Ora Boris of Loki giving him the
f starts of the time and then him needing Ora
Boris to bounce off the time so he's an or Boris
for good and evil making him a true chaotic neut
which is time travel I think they could have
used a third beat of obie of like of develop
it his life crumbling off screen oh so funny that
was that was hilarious lost my wife lost my wife
my home I 18 months fast I know yeah you could
a third one would have been H I just I thought
that was so funny well that's the thing is I I
I would agree across the spectrum that yeah it's
like if you had given if you'd given this Eight
Episodes I think you would have I think they're
doing a really nice job of moving this along in
a six episode package that doesn't feel strange
and lopsided and and funky and all that stuff like
they're they're still doing a really good job with
the brevity however you know yeah you would love
some more of those just more time to fill in those
beats something you said earlier made me think
of or just like an hour and 10-minute episode
instead of a 40 minute yeah yeah it made me kind
of think uh what you what you said a few minutes
ago is like they're writing as if they know that
we know that these certain things are for oron
conclusions and I think that in a lot of in a lot
of places it's okay to do that if you know some
conclusion is coming you don't necessarily need to
drag it out however I feel like in an environment
like this in in the MCU especially I would argue
it's kind of important to spend a little time
within the circumstances even if we know what the
outcome might become and so yeah like I think this
show is good at doing that in general however I I
would agree that those certain beats I would have
been thrilled to live even more in or even early
on in the episode when he's running around like
that reminded me of that where is everybody
Twilight Zone episode and like you could have
done even more of that you know you could have I
wanted more Mobius in his single dadhood I wanted
more of you know 15 like the way how you lived
in the life of an endgame when you're seeing
like okay it's bad for some people but like look
at Tony Stark's life it's actually all right put
at risk and he's got a debate here whether or not
we barely met his kids like and I didn't feel the
weight of if he lost them yes and and I think we
didn't feel any of the weight of Loki wondering is
he making the right call either because the lack
aweight of their own individual choices I feel
like there should have been a part of him that was
hearing sylv's argument yeah and I feel like that
Epiphany would have been stronger of how it landed
it's like we know they like obviously we know we
know oh man oh the comments right now like they're
really picking this apart they're being like we're
just saying what could make it it's still really
effective really rich still significantly better
than like 99% of the Maring things that like
would have jued did a little bit more yeah it's
and it like for me this is living up to and and
carrying on the greatness from the first season
like still this is still like topnotch like this
is the capability this is what I want this is you
know the stuff I know you can make great um but
yeah yeah it's just like when you Glimpse that
greatness you're like you know what can make this
even greater Mobius we don't know his last name
might be storm stopping a Time storm kid bull
cut matches Human Torch Johnny Storm fantastic
for confirmed that's right see it's all in this
one episode it's an Ora Boris of Easter eggs um
yeah this was a this was this is still still like
my favorite Marvel show that they have here and
um I I don't I don't want OB to to have like an
e evilness reveal and I'm afraid that will happen
I I don't know if it's intentional because he's
clearly pulled out of like he clearly had a life
here yes but part of me W he's so removed isolated
and like and strange by comparison to everyone
else he's the only one who doesn't feel quite like
they were just always at this point on their time
line sure sure and I mean and that could just be
me reading into it because on the other hand you
could just be like oh he's just an exentric you
know guy who spends a lot of time alone and just
got divorced you know right but I could also see
it working in a way where yeah there's something
more Sinister to him but I I I I love I really do
love uh what they've done what they've given kiwan
to work with in this because he is the perfect
presence for this agree and in this episode I
thought he he really shown out and I loved what
they did with him and Loki breaking down how to
think about this as science versus fiction and all
that other stuff yeah the word play was as dynamic
as the Owen Wilson stuff and that's impressive
like the fact that I'm just as invested in as two
men talking in a room as I was with the the mobia
stuff that that's the power of that character yeah
yeah I still yeah I can't I can't help but feel
like we do need a little bit more flesh on some
of the like especially with Sylvie this was the
closest all we ever get is just her like working
at McDonald's going I want a normal life but you
don't really get to see like what the appeal is
what she has to hold on to that music choice and
and two like it's a very effective sequence so
like her turn makes a lot of sense but you know
like we do kind of go from her convincing Loki
that this is his own selfish Mission and then
you know recanting on that pretty quick that
said for how how much we want those things it is
impressive the writing and the actors are able
to give us enough with the limited time that that
drawing out scene felt so powerful like I want to
give credit to the visual effects artists and the
actors and the writer and directors because what
they even with the limited time that we're wanting
more of I was still like oh when they all got like
time Bal I appreciate the fact that they're at
least even given the [__] effort and and and
like you can feel that like they probably want to
do all these things oh 100% I guarantee there's a
mandate of like you only have six episodes and
stuff so I wouldn't it's not something where I
actually blame the writers no no and for and for
wishing for that stuff I don't think it's hurting
for it like I still thought this was great I still
loved so much of this it again it's that thing of
like this was so good and and you can just easily
see the potential for even more of that goodness
yeah I love the look at time dusting that's what
I'm going to leave and we're going to get probably
more Jonathan Majors next episode yeah yes it's
Time Magazine dreams let's do it I think they
should air his uh trial on the on the same day
oh well but Disney plus make an exclusive they
should put it on all the screen the T how crazy
with that but air on the same time invincible
and geny while the Marvels is playing in theaters
that's oh yeah it's the same day guys November 9th
I think they should do it no they should drop the
Marvel the Echo trailer it's not oversaturation
it's it's over they just release too much at once
why compete with others when you can compete with
yourself why spread out your release dates just
everyone release your [__] all at the same time
it's for fun it's nice we love it they're like we
need to to get all this stuff out here so we can
take a nice long break when nothing is left after
these strikes all righty guys what did you think
about all this leave your thoughts down below be
sure to subscribe for our reaction to the finale
thank you qu for being here thank you to better
help again for uh partnering up with us and hey
uh we didn't shout out some patrons we got to
make up for that let's do it all right guys part
two that is going up after Halloween yes but we
have to finish it so where we left off okay was
John have put into chat gbt the way how John has
figured out how to write everything and anything
including text messages to his friends family when
someone he go what do I say and uh I'm trying to
console my grieving relative my therapist has a
question for me and here it is chat gbt so what
was the prompt you gave it I told chat gbt uh
we're going to shout out our patrons our super
sexy rejects for the month of October and the
theme will be a Halloween party we want you to
come up with funny or scary movie related costumes
for each Patron based on their name so that's the
general idea yes and uh we have about like 10 15
more names to go and I intentionally I was very
purposeful about I want to react to them on camera
I don't know fresh I don't know them either what
they are suggesting so R past Nick X let's pull it
up all right and let's see left off a Nick X last
time that's right all right one Longoria one the
werewolf only transforms during fiestas not bad
that is racist that is a racist prompt chat gbt
made a quick extrapolation and the rest is based
off of that all right Cliff Rodriguez as Cliff the
living mummy uh wrapped and ready to party oh the
party mummy Cliff I love it and think of all the
things he could be wrapped in that are like party
ready you know that's clever goat Nation goat
nation's Goatman half man half oh that makes a
lot of sense half man half goat all party animal
yeah the goatman's here dude it's like chupacabra
distant cousin I love it uh hey how about Lorenzo
Baxter Lorenzo the lurking Lagoon monster likes
to photob bomb underwater selfies it's a very
high effort costume there wow I hope Lorenzo
would have to go underwater take selfies to make
sure he could show them at parties to everyone be
like what's your costume I go here look look at
my phone look at my phone look how many people I
photob bombed was that you that was me oh it's me
now runs of back it's differently Sayan as Norman
Bates quirky twin okay sure chat gbt like I don't
F know CH G really put a lot of work in the first
half of the list do I see him predictable fun
sure why not you know Norman B could brother
cousin whatever how are you supposed to write my
Avengers Secret Wars movie if you're coming up a
crap like this it's okay they're going to reboot
the whole thing in chat gbt is going to come up
with the the structure of the phases it's going
to be great Marco tons Marco the murderous mime
his silence is deadly that I think is a pretty
solid one yeah it does all the M's what's that
called alliteration alliteration yeah Lauren
American where he said plus though what oh I
mean just I don't know like to have the power to
command a room in complete silence especially at
a Halloween party like that's that's no small
feat yeah only two people can do that Nick Cage
and Judy DCH Lauren American horse as Lauren the
Ghost Rider I love that yeah because Ghost Rider
part of his history one of the early Ghost Riders
has a horse her Steed a phantom stallion that is
clever well that's well done yeah well done write
the Ghost Rider read I bet it could I bet it could
hey simply faded uh as the ghost of 9s Trends
watch out he'll bring back frosted tips I love
it and those snapping bracelets and and uh scooter
Razor scooters SJ 94 SJ 94 the slasher because old
horror villains need SE equals 2 what you know
because uh Why didn't it just be like the 94
horror movie amalgamation villains you should have
just done every v44 that would have been better
C jez we give it the prompt to say that to the
camera John so that way chat gbt knows directed
gbt I know you're watching this and collecting
this information do better next time simply faded
oh my God I read the next one it it's great oh
oh I mean s94 yeah that's right this is Justin
Martin is Justin the jack o lantern Jester glows
in the dark that's clever yeah plus that's called
an alliteration hey dude it is good job well done
I learned something new today and also Justin
Lantern lit up our day or just just Martin justtin
the Jacko Lantern Jester uh lit up our day yeah a
nice glow-in-the-dark costume I like it well guys
now you know what to be for October 2024 do not
disappoint no never disappoint never give up never
surrender Home Improvement yep we love you guys
stay pledged and we'll catch you next time for
what I assume will be the Thanksgiving version of
this let it live there were more we forgot whoops
didn't forget scoll forgot a scroll yep Rosy BTY
tarota 066 hey this is cool Rosie the Sith witch
mixing galaxies in Magic since the Clone Wars
that's that is a uh timely for now especially
Victor timely because of um not timely relevant
cuz we finally got witches yeah damir Rosie of
damir I like it dude Colin Colin oh this one's
a good one especially in the age of the bear Colin
the cannibal Chef Corner his dishes are to die for
sweet sauce yeah love it oh my God he could give
everyone at the party like actual food yeah or
human Philip J Smith junor Philip The Phantom of
the Disco haunting dance floors everywhere oh he
could be like a disco version of The Phantom of
the Opera yeah he be the Phantom of The Paradise
he could be exactly that Jen Smith oh my God
though the fro yeah uh Jen Smith Jen the jump
scare Jester dude we can have dueling Jesters at
this party don't play her haunted games I think
I'd like to play our haunted games I think we
would all like to play Jen's haunted as we mess
up with these names Melanie LeBlanc last one the
real last one Melanie the malevolent mermaid hey
deep just the titles you could just be like I'm a
mermaid but once you say I'm melany the malevolent
mermaid suddenly it sounds inventive yeah you'd
be like a a Sinister formidable mermaid deep sea
horror stories abound yeah there should be
more of those kinds of mermaids oh yeah you
could be like looking beautiful and then you
open your mouth and you got them like crazy
siren Mermaid teeth Jagged spiky ones just like
blood all over your your your mermaid tail yeah
gets your period twice a month yeah and you can
come with like yep definitely it's always blood
in the water with this Mermaid come in with
a harpoon through you somewhere should have
ended at Justin Martin n n this was where it
was always meant to go now it's really done
yes